foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting for
the PODS of moving and storage Studio
this is the Ramsey show where America
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money I am at Ramsey
personality Rachel Cruz hosting it this
hour and next to me Dr John deloney
best-selling author and host of the Dr
John deloney show so we are here taking
your calls it's a free call anywhere in
the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five and that's about
what the advice is worth all free free
you may love it you may hate it well who
knows what's going to happen
and we have a Lobby full of people on
this Friday and so just to remind
they're all clapping and cheering uh to
come visit us our headquarters is right
outside of Nashville in Franklin
Tennessee so come you can have a cup of
coffee some cookies Hangouts and watch
the show so you are always welcome here
all right we're gonna go to the phones
this hour to Maria in Chicago
hi Maria welcome to the show
thank you so much thank you for taking
my call and I I have a quick question
for you guys yes
um I've already investing 15 for my
retirement on my 401k through my job but
they do offer us a discount for the
stocks of the company 15 discount so I
my question is would it be smart for me
to take advantage of the discount and
only put like 10 for my 401k and the
other five percent on their stocks since
it's a discounted rate
you know Maria the company stocks it's
not it's not my favorite place to invest
because there's a little bit of putting
all your eggs in one basket even though
you're getting a discount I hear that
but the idea of more diversification and
spreading your money around and so
keeping some money yes in your 401k uh
and I would even what's their match
what's their match percentage in their
401K for our 401K they match the first
four percent 100 and then the next two
percent is uh 50 okay Maria do you have
a Roth IRA
I have it but I only I'm not able to put
a lot of money in there because since me
and my husband both of us are putting 50
15 on 401k and then trying to put 100
100 extra to our mortgage then it's not
enough room to put extra money to that
Roth IRA I only put twenty dollars so I
know it's not a lot but I at least put
twenty dollars every month yeah no I
hear that totally so one piece of advice
Maria I would give you is just to do
them like run some math and even talk to
a Smart investor Pro uh if you guys have
a great if you don't have a great
financial uh advisor I would check one
of them out but um but even look to see
okay what if you went up to the match of
the 401K up to that four percent see how
much it would take of your percentage of
your income to go and invest and see if
you can even max out your Roth IRA and
then come back to your company's 401k
and put some more in if you haven't
reached that 15 so I would look I would
hate there I love the idea a Roth IRA is
just one of my favorite things John
because gross tax-free and if you're
able not even to Max it out but to
contribute even more because of that
growth it's just a wonderful thing it's
one of my favorite retirement Vehicles
when it comes to investing so I would I
would run some numbers Maria on your
situation and again look to see okay if
we just put in four percent and took
them took up to the match of the company
see what percentage is left of your
income and how much would be to max out
your Roth IRA and if there's any any
more percentages left to that 15 pie go
back to your company's 401K but I would
not to your original question invest in
your company stock I my mom worked at
this little company when I was a kid
called Enron and they were notorious for
being so generous with the greatest
stock on planet Earth by selling it to
their employees for cheaper and then
they built an extraordinary amount of
wealth on the back of their employees
and the people that were close to us
that went to bed but jillionaires and
woke up literally Rachel with no nothing
with nothing so she really worked for
Enron that's like story of the absolute
worst of the worst of the worst the
historic story Deloitte and then went to
Enron went back to Deloitte so she's
about them but it was this it just all
went away yes it all went like the
whatever it was the third or fourth
largest company on planet Earth it just
didn't exist right just like a vapor and
so I think the idea of company stocks I
get it and I appreciate them being kind
and I don't think every company is like
Enron
um it's just not where I'm gonna trust
my yeah trust my I've already got enough
invested in you with our like I'm doing
work you're giving me my paycheck right
I'm not going to put that much more I'm
going to spread the rest of it out
that's great that's great all right up
next we got Jack in Grand Rapids hey
Jack welcome to the show
thanks guys how you doing we're doing
great how can we help
all right so I have a question about the
I guess the morality of my job so what
do you do man person I'm a car sales
person
you're a murderer or something you're
dealing drugs that's not here what I was
hoping you were gonna say okay yeah
sorry it's not as interesting maybe as
you hope um yeah so obviously huge part
of my job is signing people up for car
loans
um which ever since listening to you
guys I don't
I don't entirely agree with I don't
think it's the right path and I I kind
of feel bad for customers but at the
same time I know it's you know my duty
uh to do that so I'm just I've been
struggling a little bit with kind of the
moral responsibility of that I know I'm
not the one signing them up I'm not the
finance person but you know I know
what's happening I know what's happening
so I'm going to go in the office and
just something I've been dealing with
I'm giving advice of you know am I more
responsible for that should I be seeking
some other work because this job has
been a big blessing for my family so
just maybe seeking some guidance with
that I think every Everybody I've ever
met has a moment when they
walk by the mirror and look in it and
ask himself is the job they're doing or
the people they're working for or the
culture of their job or the time away
from family that has some sort of value
misalignment and they have to ask
themselves is this okay with me and so
what I would tell you is I've got my
personal opinion I think it's way more
valuable for you to make that choice and
it sounds like you've made that choice
you just realize like and I go back to
people who and again this isn't about
the facts or anti-vaxx but people were
told to keep your job you will get this
vaccination and some said okay and some
said I'm gonna forgo my
paycheck because uh I'm not doing this
um often our values cost us something
and it sounds like your values you know
what you feel you don't feel good about
what you're doing and again I've got
people working who I love who are in the
car industry so that's not that's why
I'm not putting it put it out there but
for you you're having a harder time
looking in the mirror and so I would
tell you
um
go with your guts what your values are
and then know this probably gonna cost
you something and it's not something by
the way you have to walk in on on Monday
and quit right it might be something
right this is not going to be what I do
the long-term play yeah we've had many
people bankers and they end up doing
this and like I just can't anymore and
here's the old two Jack and we say this
all the time that that debt is not a sin
right this is not a Salvation issue this
is not a thing that like it's it's not
you can have debt and you know in the
faith world still love Jesus like go to
heaven right like this is not a
Salvation issue but it is down to a
little bit of that moral dilemma for
yourself and how do you feel do you feel
good at them today and I think some
people can hold that and walk forward
and some people can't just out of a
personal conviction yeah we call those
people Psychopaths right I'm just
kidding no no no no no no no no no but
but yeah it's it that's one of those
areas that's different for everybody so
yeah they can hold it in different ways
right or am I a psychopath maybe I mean
I got a tick tock account I do it every
day like what am I doing you're a
YouTuber John trust me I know all right
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting at this hour with Dr
John deloney and we are taking your
calls on life money relationships career
anything and everything we are here
to have a conversation to chat answer
your questions and yeah have a good old
time all right John oh we're having a
good old time good old time all right I
have a barn raisin that's right so
it says at triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's a free call
anywhere in the country all right up
next we have Stacy in Chicago hey Stacy
welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me absolutely
how can we help
I had a question
um that I had some advice given to me by
my financial planner and he I have a lot
of medical expenses and I was told that
for anything of this calendar year if I
have any unreimbursed medical expenses
beyond my 10 of my AGI I can take
anything out penalty free and I have
about
um I have well beyond the 10 of my egi
for medical expenses
um and so I was just trying to to lay
out the pros and cons on whether or not
I should do that or just pay it down
because currently the expenses are on my
credit card
okay so how much in total are your
expenses
I have close to 33 Grand 33 000 okay
and what other debt do you have
I have some uh credit card debts right
now that's about like 12 Grand okay
um and then I have medical expenses also
on those credit cards from last year
which is about 18 Grand does that is
that 18 included in the 33 that you were
talking about or in addition to no it's
separate okay okay
anything else student loans car loans
um I have about 16 000 left in student
loans and my car is paid off okay
how much do you make a year
I make a hundred thousand okay
um you know honestly Stacy yeah we don't
we don't encourage don't don't yeah even
though there's not a penalty there's
still going to be taxes like there's
still going to be there's still going to
be things going around in that and so
just not touching retirement is is the
goal again mostly because we don't want
you to pay taxes and penalties well I
don't say this right now the market has
been down this calendar year you will
lock those losses in Forever
this would be I can't imagine a worse
time to borrow against your 401.
to take money out on it
that makes sense yeah I mean because
that money can grow at any point in time
in the future and since it is low um I'd
be losing out on a lot for sure of yeah
of especially what can be so
um
you're gonna have 70 oh sorry what keeps
happening year over year with medical
expenses is this going to be ongoing
so given my current situation I am
trying everything in my power now to
make sure that what I am doing is
covered by Insurance
um I I think I I don't foresee this last
thing for another year or so
um currently I mean I'm no stranger to
to working hard and doing this I uh you
know I paid down hundred thousand
dollars of student loans before working
two jobs but certainly given my given my
Challenge and my current condition I
just really one job is already enough
um what's going on medically with you
um uh I have a Lyme disease and a bunch
of co-infection
um and some mold toxicity and and some
mold illness so I had to move and
there's been a lot of expenses um that
I've had to kind of try to take care of
in order to get myself into a better
environment you've locked these expenses
some of these in the the medical
expenses from last year with your credit
card have you sat down with the hospital
and tried to settle this
I mean because there's something about
saying your income is high so they may
not help they may not work with you very
much but there's something to be said
for hey I got fifty thousand dollars I
can't I can't
um what number would they settle with
um settle with you on
right and that's something I'm not sure
about I've tried to call
yeah
cut the insurance company out
um I'm talking about going directly to
your provider and sitting down I had
something done a few months ago and I
just asked hey if I write you a check
what is it and it was a quarter of what
it was of the total bill if I didn't use
insurance
a chord 25 percent
wow and it was it was it's not what
you're dealing with and so it might not
be
um it might not be so drastic but
there's something about uh if you owe
what you say 35 000
yeah about 33 for this year yeah if you
come in with ten thousand dollars cash
and say I'm I I can do this can we call
it good if I give you 10 grand a call
again
um and they may do that and Stacy and
going back to yes which I totally echoed
John for sure uh and then going back to
see your original question you know so
much of this yes is out of your hands
when it comes to the medical side
um of your bills but making a hundred
grand which I know in Chicago doesn't go
as far as somewhere else in the country
but but if you even just lived off of
and said like hey I'm gonna live like I
make sixty thousand it could take you
two and a half years and you can clean
up all of your debt all of this and with
the student loans you know and the and
even the other credit card uh which I
know you said was with medical expenses
as well but you know all of this just
looking at it and saying I am going to
just I'm gonna go scorched Earth and I'm
gonna sacrifice and I'm gonna do it like
you said I know that the medical side
that you're dealing with is going to
make it more difficult but put a goal
out there you know pulling money out if
this was a just a mutual fund out there
floating around I would say cash it out
but when it comes to just your
retirement overall it's just not a wise
thing to cash out uh stay in it don't
jump off the roller coaster and and map
your map it out too Stacy because even
in your voice it feels you sound tired
you know what it sounds like we hear
this sometimes Rachel when people call
and they've got their thousand dollars
and they're in baby step two and then
something breaks and they have to go
back and do the thousand dollars and
they've sold everything so now they're
just gonna grind it out yeah and then
they get up again and then something
else happens and it's just like you know
what screw this I'm just gonna go put on
a credit card so much easier
and we're we're the only ones telling
people
I'll sit with you because it's hard and
it's it's awful this happened but you
got to get back up and you got to go
again yeah and you got to get back up
and you gotta go again you know what I
mean and it we just at some point we say
you know what you're right you deserve
it or here's a hack there's not one man
and she I hate this for you you paid off
what 85 000 in credit I mean in student
loans already a hundred thousand yeah so
you can do it that's the great thing
yeah but then just but I just in my guts
know like the feeling of oh we get to go
do all that again yeah here we go again
right so hard Stacy thanks thanks for
hang in there Stacy
all right so when it comes to changing
your life in any area of your life so
whether it's your marriage or your
mental health or your money or your
career it takes being intentional and it
takes having a set of tools to help you
in these changes and well again whether
it's even losing weight or changing a
career whatever the thing is being
intentional is so so key so that's one
reason that we created the smart
conference to give you a plan to help
really turn up that Focus turn up that
intensity uh to meet your goals in every
area of your life so we are so excited
that we're going to be in Dallas Texas
Saturday October 22nd for the smart
conference there's still some tickets
left it'll be about 6 000 people in an
arena and all the Ramsay personalities
will be there myself John Dave Ramsey
Ken Coleman George Campbell and we are
all sharing the stage to help you
Christina will be there Christina will
be there Craig Rochelle and Amy Pastor
Craig Rochelle and they're gonna be
talking about marriage and there's live
music there's chaos all day it's gonna
be a blast it's a really it is it's a
fun day it's a long day you're gonna
feel like you drink out of a water hose
because there's so much information
yes you're not out of a water house
it's gonna be relaxing and bring you
back to your childhood and the Nostalgia
of childhood
John this is why we host together I know
I'm so glad
you know I wasn't in honors class
all my AP glasses in high school are
really paying off you're gonna be
drinking out of the out of a water hose
America just like we used to in the
olden days it's gonna be fantastic so
get your tickets at ramseysolutions.com
slash
events to get your seats today and join
us in Dallas October 22nd
[Music]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting at this hour with Dr
John deloney and we're going to the to
the phones this hour and Rita in New
York
is up next welcome to the show
thank you Rachel and John how are you
we're doing well thanks for calling
what's up Rita
fantastic okay my question is should I
pay off this last day so I've been
working on my budget I'm so proud of
myself thanks for the app that you guys
have we're proud of you too Rita well
done
I'm crunching all the numbers and after
I pay this debt which is a consumer debt
of 1
320.41 I will have left in my account
um about sixteen sixteen hundred dollars
um
I'll tell you in the beginning of the
year I was I had about six thousand
dollars worth of debt it just piled on I
don't even know how I did it
um I was working at a retail store
making about 17 an hour
um but as of last month I was offered a
position making 95 000. oh wow yes doing
what Reid is a gangster dude what are
you doing I'm I'm in insurance and I
want to thank you guys too because I
used to be in Insurance about 12 years
ago
um left that to live a little more and
I've been out of insurance about seven
years now and I was listening to one of
the the shows and I don't know what
happened but you guys were just talking
about insurance
umbrellas this and that and I was like
is this a sign
[Laughter]
I reached out to a buddy who I know is
still in the insurance industry I said
Hey listen I'm thinking about coming
back and
okay read it so tell me about this debt
is it handsome
is it just so lovely
like why do you want to why do you want
to why do you want to hang on to it so
tightly it's got it
I think it's a mental thing and like in
my heart of hearts I know I can do it
like just pay it off
um I did crunch all the numbers rent
everything I'm good you know what I
think I answered my own question right
pay it off
Rita hey we're so glad are you the first
person in your family to go go down this
road
um
no I don't think so I think I'm the only
one who's taking a stand on it that's
what I mean that's what I mean okay so
here here's I can imagine this is just a
psychological thing
you're about to cross a line that was
always in your life for other people
other people didn't owe money other
people
got to sleep all night and not worry
about how their bills were going to get
paid other people and now you're about
to step over a line
that really doesn't exist by the way
but you're going to step over a line and
you're going to become the other person
now
and often we get hung up right before
that that's why weight is so hard to
lose because man oh those people the
skinny people just gets is hard right
and we can fill in the blank oh they
drive those kind of cars
um so you're about to cross the line and
what Rachel and I would tell you is
don't just step over that line Sprint
across it screaming and yelling the
whole way
okay because there is no other people
we're all in this big sinking ship
together so just run across it as fast
as you can cheering all the way okay and
you make 95 Grand your emergency fund
will be built up in what three months
you'll be good to go yes yes I already
have the um the thousand dollars in
there
um and I I have a retirement one from my
previous job I have a hundred and thirty
thousand radar Rita right now you're
trying to make this a math problem
you're free lady
okay you're free you got it Rita do it
do it today do it today done and then oh
I just cut off I'm so sorry Rita
I was just gonna tell her Rachel's the
hospitable one on the show no uh but
isn't that it is you're free it I'm like
it's right there and it's almost this
intimidation of oh is this real like is
this yeah what is this and I get going
down to 1600 which we say a thousand
dollars so you're even 600 buffered more
than what we even would say I think she
has her thousand bucks I think when she
pays it all she's still gonna have 1600
bucks in her account with that yeah yeah
yes and so yeah you got this Rita and
and well done on pursuing a whole new
career she's working retail making 18 an
hour and just thinks huh I could get
back to Insurance how many times do we
hear that when somebody's getting when
they cross the halfway point
of their debt-free Journey they just
start walking taller and demanding like
I don't have to live like this yes and
then also they get promoted get new jobs
making 95 Grand
Rita you did it Well Done Rita we are
cheering you on sleep well tonight
knowing that it's paid off it's paid off
it's awesome well only free person in
New York that's awesome
all right up next we have Chad here from
Nashville awesome hey Chad welcome to
the show
hey thank you guys for your time today
absolutely how can we help
so we began our uh uh debt Journey here
about 11 weeks back it's going
phenomenal we're on track to uh be
debt-free except for mortgage come the
end of this January
um and one of life's circumstances has
just kind of shown up uh one of the
unique ones where my dad who lives in
Michigan uh he's 82. and he's no longer
able to safely live on his own
um
and
uh a combination of the siblings that
are up there
um who are either not willing or able to
provide any more help and he only has a
two thousand dollar a month
um social security check that he gets so
from when I've looked into assisted
living is is just beyond his means
um with that check he has nothing
basically nothing in savings
um so me and my wife talked about it and
with her support we convinced him to
come and stay with us to help them okay
um and thank you to my beautiful wife
for that because she's been amazing well
I'll I'll personally think his
um
remarkable son too because this y'all
are working hard y'all had a picture of
what this was going to look like and all
of a sudden that picture's gone and
y'all are having to scramble to paint
something new like right you're having
to change the oil on this thing while
it's driving down the road and so good
for you man that's hard it's a hard
choice and I'm proud of you man it's
hard
thank you
um the so the the couple a couple things
I wanted to throw at you guys and get
your opinion on there's a couple so
first we were thinking as far as him
coming down here
um contributing to the household
um we're you know we're talking about
you know maybe just if he contributed
you know just for groceries
um out of what he gets three to three
hundred dollars for the month for
groceries and we're talking about
um
maybe having him put
uh ten thousand dollars aside for his
own personal emergency fund
um it was kind of the ideas we were
tossing around for him and talking with
him and is this for
um your motivation for this Chad is it
yeah what's he in emergency fund for
because he has to go to the hospital or
something
yeah General emergencies and if uh for
the day that we hope is still a long
ways out
um celebration of life you know expenses
okay
so here's the thing too it's common that
when our worlds blow up
that we try to solve that explosion
through extra means of control
and what you're doing now is things blew
up and your dad's moving in it wasn't in
the plan but here we are you're
disappointed your brothers and sisters
here we are
and now you're starting to rehearse
tragedy that might be 5 or 10 or 15
years away
I would recommend get settled I do love
the idea of giving him a role to play
financially in the home that sounds
counter-intuitive but gives dignity
gives dignity yes hey hail man you're
paying rent you see what I'm saying like
he's got a he's gonna participate even
if it's a little bit and that will give
him some
uh responsibility there and then I think
you'll have a hard conversation about
recommendations and savings and things
like that
um
I don't know Rachel it's hard to tell
your dad what he's going to do with his
money I know he's living under your roof
this whole thing's flip-flopped but yeah
and getting his his thoughts as well
Chad having that conversation it's a
dialogue and to say hey let's do this
together and figure it out because we
both we all want the same outcome we
want to have a peaceful household and
how can we do that well but we dealt we
commend you Chad you and your wife both
um for doing this it's very power of
attorney too by the way
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
four three
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Rachel Cruz with Dr John deloney taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five and up next we
have John in New York so how are you
today we're doing great thanks for
giving us a call how can we help
all right I have a tough one okay I have
170 000 remaining ballots on my 15-year
fixed mortgage okay 2.0 rates it's a
great rate
financial advisor and accountant insist
I should not pay it off as they all do
however I have about 170 000 in savings
the problem is I skipped the baby steps
and I have no College savings for the
kids
if I pay it off
I have no other debt I can immediately
start that so I did skip that 80 step
what's your mortgage
170. sorry no what do you pay every
month in your mortgage
principle of interest is about 2600.
okay how old are you including the
property tax
uh 11
and five okay okay and household incomes
about 400. oh nice okay okay can I tell
you what I'm doing in my house
yes sir
um if I have a 12 year old and a
six-year-old
and if I was in your exact exact same
boat
and I had 170 000 in savings
I would pay my house off before the end
of the day is over
and full stop you know I've always
gotten the yeah I love it I've always
gotten the advice that God willing I can
continue to work and when they start
college I'd pay for that out of my
earnings
so I never really
you know started anything up yeah with
the anticipation that I would hopefully
pay this off
absolutely yeah
if I pay it off though emergency fund is
gone so I should probably wait a few
months to get that yeah I'm gonna say
don't cash it all out that's including
emergency funds yeah yeah I think so
don't do that that would
yeah it keeps keep three months
and then yes and then but write a big
check tonight I mean like have have a
level of it to be like okay we're we're
getting there and yes what you're saying
with your income yeah with your income
level
um obviously depending on where your
kids go to school because they all won't
be in school together at the exact same
time that you may be able to cash flow
it completely uh just off of your income
but the question is yeah will you will
you have that
that same level of income in 10 years
let me do this here's some back of the
napkin math okay I'm just using my cell
phone calculator here if you take that
twenty six hundred dollars that you pay
every month
um and multiply it by 12 that's 31 000 a
year you're sending not including your
taxes okay
your child is 11. is that what you said
your oldest yes okay so it's seven years
until they go to college
so if I just take Thirty one thousand
dollars times seven that's 218 that's
220 000 bucks
that you can have by not changing your
life in any shape form or fashion just
continuing to pay your mortgage
see what I'm saying
yeah that's not cash flowing that's just
if you just kept making your mortgage
payment and stuck it in a in a zero-sum
I mean a zero percent earning checking
account
you still you'd still be way ahead of
most parents
so you feel you know do this in two
steps do a big chunk build the emergency
fund up get it to three months and then
finish it off yeah otherwise you're
going to write 170 000 check and you're
gonna go screaming down Manhattan
Boulevard tonight so happy and then
tomorrow morning your air conditioner is
going to break
and then okay you're not gonna be happy
anymore
but the fact that it's a it's a good
rate and it's two percent and you know
it's a it's an attractive mortgage so to
speak that has no bearing whether my
rate's two percent or five percent it
really doesn't yeah and that's what
makes us weird this is why this is where
we're different than majority of a
financial advisor or a tax Pro out there
or at least ones that we don't recommend
at Ramsay but the the norm out there is
that they're playing a math game John so
on the math side could you invest that
mortgage payments you know or uh or keep
the mortgage and not have you know have
a low interest rate I mean all the the
math game that is played in that
industry like there's a there I like we
have brains like we see it we're like
that I get what they're saying where you
could take this chunk of money and
invest it and you can make more in the
market versus what you're you know
having to pay an interest on your house
all that like mathematically
there's a yeah like I get it that could
happen but John yeah but John like what
what Freedom does to you and what peace
does to you when you don't owe anyone
anything
changes the game you're in you're in
downtown New York
uh no Suburban New Jersey okay think
back to 30 months ago
I Rachel and I were in downtown
Manhattan when they came out of Broadway
and said Broadway is closed until
further notice as covet was kicking off
we were in there in March I think March
yeah we had a big work event that we
were doing and we were all down there
yeah all the rooms and personalities and
we were literally there yeah go back to
that moment and imagine not having a
house payment
do you give do you give a crap what the
interest rate is back then no not really
no and then the idea of or the age-old
saying of cash is king and you know
holding cash and having more than your
emergency fund and just sitting on it
while you have the mortgage
that we that's a fallacy in your opinion
right it's like cash is King but I have
debt so you're solving for Freedom right
you're solving for freedom
and all when you have when you have debt
and you've got savings all you're doing
is holding the bank's money for them
it's not your money because you owe it
correct yeah so you have cash is King
but you don't have cash you've got their
money just in your account so I would
just give it to them like what is Happy
Gilmore say just
send them home just send them out just
oh man hey congratulations my brother
and John well done 90 days you're free
appreciate it that's it I know well done
John you've done a fantastic a fantastic
job absolutely incredible and yeah and
that and that's what's interesting about
what we what we encourage you guys to do
is again debt is so normal and people
play the math game over and over and
over and over and over and what's not in
the math game is risk what's in the math
game is not fear what's not in the math
game is sleeping at night what's not in
the math game is not owing anyone
anything and having literally no one
that has their name on your paycheck I
mean there is just something to be said
that can't be put in a formula
but we are as human beings like our soul
who we are and how we function
there's a lot there that again a tax Pro
isn't always going to just sit down and
and help you have those conversations
well I'm always just oh this is hard man
but I always want to ask somebody when
they're giving advice
do you stand to benefit from this advice
right and that's why I appreciate
calling us we're just a neutral third
party out here on the airwaves and I'll
tell you what I'm gonna do in my house
right I'm actively working to set myself
up to be in the position that John is
yeah right for that very reason and my
interest rate is almost identical to his
it's it's basically nothing right yeah
um and it's not about the interest rate
it's about absolutely being free
and here's the great thing too if you
want a mortgage again after you pay it
off you can always go yeah if you like
miss it and you're like oh you really
want that organs to pay it back
we're gonna go back and get one your
wife's gonna tell you hey have a candle
at dinner say I have a hard thing to I
need to tell you he's going to think
what is it she'll say I missed the
mortgage dismiss that mortgage I miss
all that money that 2600 just leaving
all right
um next we have Aaron in Knoxville hey
Aaron welcome to the show hey man we're
right up against the clock uh go as
quick as you can
uh okay I got a really simple quick
question I've started the ever dollar
app uh this month for the first time and
I have showing
742 dollars left remaining I don't know
what I'm supposed to do with that mail
that to Ramsey Solutions attention
Rachel Cruz I'll take it Aaron
congratulations Aaron that's a good
problem to have okay do you have any
savings right now
um I'm currently fixing to officially
start maybe step one in October all
right you have to try to learn how to
use it I love it Aaron so great so great
did you get the app do you also have
Financial Peace University
the lesson okay I want you to hold on
the line Jenna's gonna pick up and we're
gonna get you uh a year subscription to
Financial Peace University as well
because that's going to be able to go
really in depth uh with this information
so Aaron that 700 is going to go towards
baby step one until you build up a
thousand dollars and then any extra
money you have left over in the months
coming with extra work Selling Stuff
cutting your budget down is gonna go to
baby step two and it's gonna help you
start the debt snowball and paying off
your debts great job Aaron I'm so
excited for you so excited for you go
Vols
foreign
[Music]
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million people listen to the
Ramsay show every week a lot of those
people listen on one of our 600 plus
radio stations across the country to
find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
ten nine eight seven six five four three
[Music]
live the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsay show we are
broadcasting live from the headquarters
and from PODS of moving and storage
Studios and this is where we hang out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money it's a free call anywhere in
the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm at Ramsey
personality Rachel Cruz hosting this
hour with Dr John Delaney bestselling
author and at Ramsay personality and
we're taking your calls on life
relationships money career all of it
anything and everything so give us a
call Triple eight eight two five five
two two five starting us off this hour
Sarah out of Tacoma Washington hey Sarah
welcome to the show
so
um I have two
um
things that I have going on in my
marriage
um oh you're lucky I've got like 15
things going on in my marriage I just
got two that's awesome
so one
that I have
um
to um
I I I noticed that my spouse has an
issue with uh drinking
and my second issue is
um our finances
we have our finances separate and so I
not sure what he's doing with his money
and he's not sure what I'm doing with my
money so I had suggested marriage
counseling my spouse doesn't want to do
it I had suggest counseling for him he
doesn't want to do it so I I'm like what
do I do next I'm like kind of are you
safe
yes okay
um when you say he's got a problem with
alcohol what does that mean
um there's not a lot that can be done
with finances there's not a lot of work
that can be done on your marriage until
he's sober
um the person you left out of the
hey maybe we should go to marriage
counsel and maybe you should go to
marriage counseling with me maybe you
should go to counseling the person you
left out is the only person you can
actually do something about and that's
you
yeah I mean I'm going to counseling from
my own personal issues good for you but
it's kind of yeah it's kind of tough
when you have someone that's dealing
with their own demons that's like
you know how am I supposed to
um get healthy how am I supposed to
um you know heal if I'm dealing with
someone I'm I don't want to say someone
when I'm dealing with a hurting spouse
when they have their own issues
absolutely I mean it's this is a
question millions of people ask are
forced to ask all the time how do I get
well in an unsafe environment and what I
would tell you is at some point you've
got to draw some boundary lines and say
whether that's I've got to take 30 days
and go stay with a friend I've got to
step right here for a minute and get my
head clear and get my relationships
clear and get my health clear
um or I'm gonna need to step away for 30
days uh on a very intentionally planned
uh separation here while you go get well
and if you're not interested in getting
well then I understand that you're not
interested in
um us working on this you see what I'm
saying like you're there's a point when
you have to draw some pretty firm
boundaries when you are married to
somebody who is struggling with
addiction because like you're noticing
it makes you financially insecure which
makes you at the end of the day very
unsafe
yeah right you don't know what he owes
what he's spending it on where it's
going if rent's going to get paid if
bills are going to get paid if you're
going to food in the fridge I mean it's
a very unstable way of being
yeah exactly and um and I tried to bring
it up and I'm like Hey listen listen you
can't
and I know that feels so powerless yeah
you can't fix him you know why you're
not the problem
yeah you're not he's not doing this
because of you
and that's what makes this so hard is
that you love him and you want to just
snap your fingers and have it be okay
yeah how long have you guys been married
Sarah
um for four years four years how long
has you been drinking
um
addiction and I don't think he's ever
got the proper help yeah yeah well I
don't I don't think he has either yeah
um at the end of the day you can control
your thoughts and your actions and how
much you love him and then at some point
you've got to draw boundaries that make
sure you're safe and that you can have
peace
and those are very very complicated hard
conversations I'm glad you have a
relationship with a professional
counselor
oh you're good
yeah and that's something I'm talking
about in counseling where you know how
to draw
um boundaries and not be so like passive
how to say Hey you know if you continue
to do this like then I have to do this
that and the third that's right yeah so
that's something I'm learning in
counseling
and that's a new muscle to build Sarah
so give yourself some some Grace in that
you're right yeah if this is a new way
of looking at life in a new lens and
even a new way to communicate and say
out loud like that's scary right like if
there's even if there's like a level of
intimidation intimidation you don't want
to hurt him I mean there's so much and
if you've been a peacekeeper your whole
life when you're growing up if it was
your job to make sure not to say the
wrong thing because mom was going to fly
off the handle and dad would get mad
yeah
I don't like Conflict at all that's
right I really don't that's right
because it's like I don't like being in
situations like that because I know I
get super I'll get super super angry and
so that's something I'm learning
um also too is how to control my anger
and get my point across and if you've
been told your whole life
um how about you just shut up and you
make sure that everybody else is okay
first that what you need and what you
want and what you feel just gets
compressed like uh that just gets pushed
and pushed and eventually that stuff
comes out in rage right it comes out in
race yeah and so here's the deal you are
like we tell people um who are on baby
step one when they're just trying to get
that thousand bucks and they've been
grinding at it for two months and
they're trying
you're on the right path it's just gonna
be hard and because you're doing
something your body has never done
before and it's going to be tough
but you got this Sarah yeah and you
deserve that right like there's to to
have that peace
um and not to go super tactical as we
end uh this segment but you mentioned
about the separate accounts and we come
on the show day in and day out telling
married couples join accounts join
accounts join accounts except when
there's issues if there's a if there's a
divorce looming if there's a separation
if there's an addiction here uh we say
that's a time to actually to keep them
separate so hear me say that loud and
clear that I would not combine accounts
with him uh with an addict because it it
it's not going to help the situation you
guys need to heal your marriage first
and then out of that comes combining
your accounts and working together with
your money but the money is a totally
side subject at this point healing and
getting boundaries for you Sarah is the
number one goal so thank you so much for
calling I hope that helps
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show we are
taking your calls this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
coming up next great name coming up next
Boon and of course he's at Texas Worth
Texas Boone from Texas what's up man
welcome to the show
howdy hi how are you guys doing oh
that's what I expected that is
everything I wanted thank you Boone
thank you Boone you're a wonderful human
being what's up man I preach you're on
the right side of DFW too what's up
yes I am yes I am so
I am the only income provider for my
household
um I have a state my wife's a
stay-at-home mom we have a 10 month old
daughter
and I've been given the opportunity to
basically quit my
current job which is for a very big like
Corporation as a W-2 employee
to go work for a mom and pop shop kind
of in the same trade same job title
um was potentially making a lot more
money
but as a 1099 worker as a self-employed
contractor with no benefits so I'm kind
of
like part of me wants to do it but also
I don't want to you know in a sense put
my family in Jeopardy if it doesn't pan
out are you a lawyer
no okay
what do you do you said no no no no
uh
I uh it's called I'm a PDR technician
but it's a fancy way of saying I fixed
dents for a living for hail damage okay
yeah so what do you make now in your
corporate job and then if you were to
run just some rough numbers what would
you make if you went into a smaller
business kind of on your own it's 10.99
so so my job is a 100 commission based
um this year I'm expecting to make
between 90 and 100 000.
and if I were to switch over to the mom
and pop shop and this is just off their
word
um I kind of just met them like within
the recent months they seem like good
people
um but they said I could easily clear a
hundred thousand as a 1099
um yeah but it's just off their word you
know so you're making
similar money and the other job you have
benefits and then this one you know you
won't
um the other one is as a W-2 employee
you you have a different tax you have
different taxes 10.99 you got to pay all
of your taxes
15.
yeah
the idea is like I would be making a lot
more possibly a lot more money because
it is based off weather because I'd be
doing mainly just hail insurance jobs
there's no hail in Texas just kidding
that was awesome that was a good joke
um so so so 100 000 sorry with the mom
Pop shop that's the that's like the
floor is kind of what they're saying and
you're you're gonna be able to make way
more than that because I just heard you
say a hundred thousand
yes yes okay yeah it's easily clear it
yeah yeah
man here's
here's what doesn't sit well with me
um
you're not the illusion of safety your
quote unquote safe in this job or safe
in that job
um people say like I'm taking I make
less money for the big Corporation but
it's a safer job and I always go back to
the story we told in another hour where
my mom worked for Enron I just don't buy
it right
but
if you told me this Mom and Pop was a
family friend of yours and you'd known
him for a long time and like you had
seen the numbers and this is legit
um that's one thing
to just tag on to somebody like no
you're gonna make a hundred easy
man that makes me real uneasy to put my
wife and 10 year old baby girl on that
track train like I would be I if I'm you
I would sit down and say I need to see
your books I want to see your what y'all
reported over the last couple years I
want to see what the business is because
I can see them just salivating over a
guy like you who is out there just
getting after it for a corporation
making a hundred grand yeah
um man I'd love I don't know you know
what I mean yeah that's not right
digging more and then run all the math
out and say okay worst case scenario I'm
gonna make 110 with the mom pop but then
run out your taxes run out your benefits
of insurance run out everything
and then see how you end up versus 90 to
100 in the corporate job uh with taxes
taken out right run two formulas and
then say okay here's what I have to make
for this move to be worth it I have to
make 130 yes or whatever it may be so to
run those numbers and maybe it's not
right now Boone I mean that's okay like
you have a 10 month old at home you have
a great job and unless you just hate it
and it's a toxic environment and you're
like I just went out and changed that's
one thing but if you're if you're okay
with it and you're enjoying it uh the
other numbers just have to be a big deal
for me to make that big of a shift right
now all right you said something
important before we go to the next call
Rachel two important things one do the
real math numbers yeah too many people
like they don't want to leave their job
so they kind of like well it's gonna
cost a million dollars to buy a new
house no it's not or they are desperate
to leave their job and they're like no
we'll make it work and you can't make it
you can't just imagine math right that's
that's important one number two I mean
number one and then number two is
sit down with the person that you're
about to hit your wagon to like Dave and
I had lots and lots of meetings both
ways right him saying am I gonna let
this guy speak on behalf of my family's
name and me saying am I gonna quit my
dream job and everything I know
to am I gonna attach myself to this
dude's last name right and so do your
due diligence both ways and make sure
you feel comfortable in your soul that
this is the right move yeah that's great
all right up next we have Ethan in Boise
hey Ethan welcome to the show
hello
um so me and my fiance are 22 with two
kids we have 34 000 in debt
um we have a wedding to save for in
August that's about ten thousand we met
50K
and with this new job opportunity if I
go gazelle with overtime I'll be able to
bring in another three thousand dollars
a month
um with the debt 30 000 is in a car and
my question is do I sell the car
now
and get a small loan to get a used car
or do
I sell it privately get a little bit
more for it and then save up we'll save
up and sell it later so out of your
thirty four thousand dollars of debt 30
of it is a car
yes how much you think you could get for
it
um Kelly Blue Book said today privately
37 to 39 and then the instant cash offer
was 30. even I got a great I got a great
plan for you Ethan sell that car yeah I
need to do it go drive okay sell the car
go drive a four to five thousand dollar
beater your fiance is embarrassed to be
with you feel ashamed terrible car Ethan
terrible car even your little kids are
like are you serious I have your wedding
in August get married
you guys together combine those finances
save up between now and then for the
wedding
and wait for August
like a year from now yeah yes I would
okay sell the car today go to tomorrow
and get married you guys have two kids
together
go get married dude go get married
because we want we want to have a party
have a party have a party later
you guys are married your kids you're
living together you are married go get
go get the certificate you do it Ethan
seriously you don't wait on a wedding to
solidify your relationship that is a way
bigger deal than the wedding so you guys
can have it in August you're gonna have
a big old party and it's gonna be
amazing and wonderful and paid for in
cash paid for in cash you're gonna get
married before that though and then you
guys have you guys have four thousand
dollars left of debt after that thirty
thousand dollar car you guys can pay
that off real soon
five and pay your debt off you know 3
500 bucks in your bank account oh he's
gonna buy a car
uh that's true my bad
sell for 40. somebody will buy it when
do you think Ethan should get married
yesterday
do it soon Ethan Do It For the Weekend
surprise your wife women love to be
surprised with weddings just kidding
don't do that it's a terrible advice
it's the worst advice I've ever got on
the show do not do that whatever no but
for real though I think that I think
there's a benefit for you guys as a
couple
to be in it to solidify it there is a
level of commitment there that you guys
need together and then You're Gonna
Knock all this out and it's gonna be
it's gonna be a forever memory and have
a big party in August if you want or
sooner and live your life with your two
kids Ethan you guys are killing it sell
the car my brother build wealth change
your legacy then you got this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show taking
your call
calls anywhere in the country at Triple
Eight two five five two two five it's a
free call talk about your life your
money your career your relationships
anything and everything I'm Rachel Cruz
with Dr John deloney and going to the
phones to will in Salt Lake City hey
Will welcome to the show
hey thanks for having and taking my call
guys I appreciate it absolutely how can
we help
um So currently in my situation I'm a
school teacher uh currently and the
finances in our area just because
our uh rent is going up higher and
higher every month uh I'll be from what
I've been told I'll start paying around
1800 a month by February
um yeah it's a killer uh especially for
our pay in this area
um and so I'm looking to move outside of
the area and look at other opportunities
um I've already reached out to some
people in other districts that I know in
other areas and the pay is higher and
the rent is about a thousand dollars
cheaper sounds like a good win man
yeah especially for where it is um right
now the uh the tentative offer will be
install.net Alaska
you said other districts I thought you
meant in your neighborhood no no
absolutely not are you teaching at
Military Academy like so what like what
are you doing there in Alaska
same thing so I'd be teaching uh yeah
teaching still
um and then I'm also familiar with this
area because I go up there almost every
year for fishing every summer cool yeah
and you have a family will
uh no I do not I'm single I just have a
dog dude get it man well that's fine I'm
actually jealous what can we help you
with
um I'm just trying to get an idea of
financially what you guys think would be
realistic in terms of going from here to
moving up there a million dollars
I I am looking at uh finishing up yeah
it's all good now um I'm looking at uh
finishing up the school year here uh
because I just don't think it's the
right thing to leave in the middle of
the semester
um with the students I have
um so I want to finish up the school
year and then leave probably uh near a
bit June uh the only things I'm looking
at taking is what I can fit in the back
of a pickup pretty much
well there you go I mean it sounds like
all you need is gas money huh and
deposit money on a new place
uh yeah it's I mean it realistically the
nice part two is I'll be paid over the
summer still for my previous job because
my contract will end in August excellent
um but the only other part is that the
weirdest part I guess is I am switching
out Vehicles because in that area I am
likely going to need a truck more or
less in that area
um and I currently have a Camry imp
making payments on it monthly because
I'm on a loan plan I'm paying about 520
a month I've already talked to lenders
it's going to be way less than that it's
going to be closer to 290 once I switch
to the other vehicle
um and get up there why why would you
why would you postpone switching
vehicles
um right now the gas mileage for the
vehicle is great
um yeah but is it worth it 250 a month
in payment
you can't be saving that much money on
gas
yeah I mean I I make an extra thousand
with a side job that I use my vehicle
for currently um okay in a truck for my
size obviously what other debt okay so
how much do you have left on the car
um there's about 20 on it
um what other debt do you have once I
get it
um that's it I my parents uh yeah just
my parents were and I were fortunate
enough to I worked 80 hours a week in
college so I paid off everything awesome
good for you and how much how much do
you make a year teaching like how much
will you have for the rest of the week
currently 56 uh once I move up there it
will be 62.63 okay how much cash do you
have in the bank right now
um just very minimum I think it's about
a thousand I've just been trying to
attack that car and so that's why I'm
kind of holding off on that to try to
get enough money to move up okay
um yeah if I'm you will I mean I would
even pop I wonder if you just Kelly Blue
booked it I'm just curious of what you
could get because my goal for you when
you moved to Alaska is that you have no
payments and you have a good emergency
funds you know of maybe two months worth
of expenses just because of the
catch-all of moving I mean when you
enter into any new season whether you're
leaving college and starting a job uh
weddings kids moving I mean all of these
they just bring more expenses than
usually we expect so to have any level
of buffer is going to be really really
important so
I would be curious you know what's an if
you what you could get for it if you
Kelly Blue booked this uh
uh got got a cheap car basically had no
payments and just just saved everything
like crazy between now and Alaska once
you get to Alaska you have some money
saved and maybe even using some of that
money to buy a car and to buy your truck
in cash uh after you sell the junkie car
that you may get here in the next few
months uh putting some money together
and get maybe a crappy truck why in
Alaska if you need to and then you can
move up from there but cash flowing all
of this as soon as possible would be my
goal
um just because of this big transition
coming up I mean I would I would really
really focus on that so that would be
that's what I would do will if I woke up
in your shoes
okay awesome yeah yeah I think it's
worth about 26 27 000 currently oh wow
okay you know what I mean I would will
and what do you what do you do on it 20
uh 20. bro I would sell that yeah get a
second the weekend is over get it get a
yeah get a seven eight thousand dollar
car
uh and then just start saving some cash
to use for your truck when you get to
Alaska and an emergency absolutely man
for both of it so thanks for the call
Will and excited for you on this journey
because it sounds like you were you got
baby step one cover that thousand
dollars like you said and you're
starting to well this will be half the
time if you pay this if you sell this
thing buy a five thousand dollar car and
you save the car payment of 520 every
month you're you've launched through
baby step two and you're well in the
baby step three yeah I mean you could
really catapult that's what's so
fascinating John about this stuff is
like it's these moves slingshot yeah
these little moves right that can just
get you there and there's a lot of
people there's nothing like shame you
will but just as an example that are
driving you know a family and they got
two crappy cars they're not worth
anything to sell they're paid off but
they're working through their credit
card debt and their student loans and
they just wish
they could have this like kind of magic
pool of like oh my gosh I could like
make this one move and then it's all
gone that's right and it's all gone that
would be amazing so I think you're just
an incredible position to really uh
catapult you forward in the baby step so
thanks so much for the call
all right blinds.com find out for
yourself by blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promo codes
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code Ramsey to get the
best deal today's question comes from
Ryan in North Carolina Ryan writes I
have a 14 year old daughter who has a
large sum of money from a settlement
because of a school bus accident that
occurred when she was 10. this money is
currently held in an accident in an
account in her name that will all be
given to her when she turns 18 and my
wife and I cannot do anything at it
without a judge's order until she turns
18. my question is how can we best help
her to prepare to invest it when that
time comes she has more than enough to
pay for college and we want to make sure
she uses it responsibly it's a great
question I'm sorry for the accident
though so this is
I love this question and here's why as a
parent it's so easy for me to parent by
I have something you don't have
I've got food you have to do what I say
or I've got bigger muscles than you you
have to do what I say
and all the literature tells me that's a
terrible way to enter into a lifelong
relationship with your kid and most
importantly teach them to become good
adults and there's moments when you have
to step in that Gap but this parent is
facing the other side of it which is my
daughter's about to have a whole bunch
of them right and so my influence over
here is a is four four years and
counting
and what I would tell you Ryan is you
double triple quadruple down on a couple
of things one relationship you can't
lead this this young woman by
um I've got something you you can't lead
like that it's got to be hey let's sit
and talk about this or let's have a
regular scheduled time together so we
can develop relationships so that four
years from now when she asks you a hard
question you've built a well of trust
that she trusts you the second thing is
she's watching every move you make with
your money and so the better you are
with your money the more likely she is
to follow into that same yep and talk
about it I would make it as normal as
possible so it's not like when she's 18
it's like here's thirty thousand dollars
what yeah that it's so normal that's
like oh yeah that's been there I know
that's the money there's no shopping and
there's already a plan for it yes you
talk about it talk about it talk about
it and the more normal it is the more
she understands why behind it there's a
level of maturity there that she
hopefully will make the right decisions
But ultimately too when she turns 18.
she's 18 right she's off to see the
wizard yeah and my hope is you've got a
relationship that she will ask you to
come along
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Rachel Cruz with Dr John deloney hosting
this hour and taking your calls up next
we have Bruce in Boston hey Bruce
welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
oh I'm in kind of a mess
um but my wife and I have been married
for 20 years back in 2010 we were
totally debt free right everything hey
talk into the phone man
when uh right after that we bought two
brand new vehicles
and from that point uh forward we have
been disconnected not able to get on the
same page I'm doing a monthly budget
uh fast forward to now
um she got a new job about a year ago
and uh the new job has her uh using her
credit card our credit card to make
purchases for the company
a company pays for those purchases but
uh I think that the company should be
get their own credit cards and they make
their own purchases not us yeah
I would agree with that so what's your
question
how do I get her to understand uh that
the company should be purchasing their
own materials
I think it's a bigger question yeah so
you can't come at the at the tail end of
of
I mean are you guys getting off kilter
buying two new cars back in 2010
that's not the reason you can't have a
budget there's something beneath the
thing that you're talking about
yep I would agree with that what is it
um I would say
um
part of his budget not not wanting to do
a budget nope no no that's not it what's
beneath that
why does she not want to
I think she's afraid of
um money commitment
she thinks she's not going to have any
money to spend even though we do have
plenty of money to spend why do you
think she feels that way
um
she came out with money controlling I'm
not money controlling I just like to do
a budget I don't spend a whole lot just
on what's needed
are you a safe person to Anchor to
probably not
I'm not the most uh communicative yeah
and so you see how over 15 years
um or 12 Years A Dance emerges
where you're hard to talk to you're hard
to connect with so she has to create a
world that she can exist in
and in that world the only joy she's got
is buying crap
and the only safety she has is Financial
Security I've got the ability to get
whatever I need whenever I need it and
you
feel like the road keeps getting pulled
out from under you
and it's frustrating and you don't know
how or don't want to say anything
and then this Just Dance starts and then
you end up further and further and
further apart and now she's in a
situation that I think is asinine it's
insane that a company is asking an
employee to put things on their on their
personal credit card that's just dumb
it's just dumb
um but y'all you you don't have the
tools you don't have the relational
Equity to have this conversation
I would agree and now it sounds like a
personal attack on her she's saying oh
you hate my job you which is an identity
thing it's all you see what I'm saying
you having this and you're right you're
actually right the the I usually don't
like to say that in a marriage
conversation you're right and that's not
the point right now
right the point is she can't hear you
and you can't hear her are you all done
um well we've been
battling on the safe for the last 15
years and um I would say we are not done
because we still love each other and uh
we have worked on we've gone to
counselors a couple of times
and uh since code then they went to
remote and that didn't work for us and
for the last two years we have not seen
anybody why
um so we couldn't do the whole remote
thing of in-person work for us better we
haven't gotten back to anybody since
that's what I'm asking in a while that's
what I'm asking you is like if I need
antibiotics and there's a flood and I
can't get to
Walgreens to go get them the moment the
water recedes I'm going to be banging on
that door to go get my what I need to be
healthy and well
okay uh I'm gonna put you on the spot
John absolutely because you've done this
in another call at previous shows and I
was like I feel like that this could be
Bruce you've painted a picture before of
a husband going out to dinner with his
wife holding her hands looking across
the table and just speaking to her and
saying out loud the truth of what they
both know
and him admitting
you know baby I've not been I'm not an
easy person to talk to
here's the situation that I know I've
create and start saying out loud the
things that you guys know and I feel
like a wife hearing her husband take
responsibility and at least
acknowledging what's going on is a
really beautiful thing do you remember
doing it all the time well say it to him
because I'm like that's a great picture
because it gives like you always say
paint the picture this picture of a
husband and wife sitting across from
each other and they're actually being a
helpful conversation
but it starts with responsibility that's
right so um what Rachel's getting to is
is is this at the end of the day you
can't make your wife do anything
it's frustrating
she's gonna have to choose to either a
com see the light about how much more
peaceful her life can be with Financial
Security or
especially in the beginning choose to
meet her husband's needs because she
loves him more than she loves
um
feeling warm and fuzzy at night for a
season okay so all you can deal with is
your thoughts and your actions and so
this whole Healing Begins
with you going to dinner
or you taking her out to breakfast one
morning and haven't already written this
stuff out
and you hold her hand and you look
across the table at her and say not we
need to or you need to know I have
screwed this up for 15 years
and that's you being ownership being
husband yep that's extreme ownership
it's you taking a knee and saying all I
can own up to is what I've contributed
to this and then here's the important
part after you take ownership here's the
scary vulnerable part for you that
part's actually easy I screwed this up
I'm sorry here's the hard part you
saying here's what I really need
here's what I need
and you'll feel less than you'll feel
small you'll feel not like the Boston
man that you think you are
but I'll tell you the time when I my
marriage was on the Rocks brother and I
sat down and one of the things I told my
wife is I said I'm ashamed to even say
this out loud I'm a six foot two Texas
male
but I need you to say you're proud of me
because I'm working as hard as I can for
one thing that's to make you proud
and I just want you to say that I'm
doing a good job
I just needed to hear that and it was
embarrassing to say and it was a moment
of catharsis for me to say it out loud
and my wife said man it would have been
awesome to know 15 years ago and now she
doesn't miss a beat and I wish I didn't
need that dude I wish I was so cool I
did I just wanted my wife to think
because I really try to impress her and
I wanted to be enough for her and so
it's you mining you going way down in
the depths and saying what do I need I
feel scared and terrified and unsafe
with how much money we owe I'm terrified
it would mean the world to me if you
help me feel more safe by doing a budget
with me
that's totally different than you need
to get your butt on a Ramsey plan you
see what I'm saying
yes that's totally me okay yeah yeah
don't do that because you know what I'm
not talking to you either man and I'm
gonna go it doesn't work yeah no it
doesn't work so this is a total this is
going to take some time for you to write
down your needs to be honest with
yourself here's what I need because it
starts out with I need more more sex
what I really need is more undivided
attention from you I need your attention
I miss you I need intimacy I need us to
just be like hang out all right so it
starts in these big announcements I need
to just get out of debt I'm terrified at
how fragile our economic situation is in
our home
you see there's a difference there man
and I want you to get to those needs and
write them down and take her out
um and have that conversation stay on
the line I'm going to send you the
questions for humans cards for couples
it'll give you all some things to talk
about as you're having these hard
conversations and it'll give you some
tools to practice having conversations
again that's great thanks Bruce thanks
for calling us
um hope all well for you you and your
wife all right thanks to James Ben Zach
Andrew Austin Jenna
in the booth the lady the lady back
there yes yes we're the only two in the
show all right thank you America for
listening this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the Pods at
Moving and Storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I am Ramsay personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney best-selling author rims
personality and host of the Dr John
deloney Michelle her name is kind of a
tongue twister
it's a little tough there for a second
you're talking so slow was I
yes you were did I I just felt like a
good Cadence they're saying no in the
booth no all right well give us my brain
is working give us a call at Triple
Eight two five eight two five five
that's what I'm talking about triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right first up this hour we have
Luke in Denver hey Luke welcome to the
show
hey guys thanks for taking a call
absolutely how can we help
um I got a multiple two-part question
um I own a house with two High School
buddies of mine and I recently decided I
wanted to leave for a couple reasons uh
one is I'm not really feeling
comfortable in the partnership anymore I
feel like they're taking advantage of
the uh of the property
and I'm feeling a bit uh taken advantage
of and the others I would love to use
the money uh a new house for my wife and
son
so I've asked to be bought out and
they're kind of refusing to and they're
refusing to sell as well
what what is the uh what's the did you
all open LLC or did just somebody's yeah
we have it okay we have an LLC why don't
they want you to to buy out
I think they're they're a bit nervous to
get um uh
uh alone right now with the interest
rates
but I'm asking I feel like to me I'm
asking a fair price I've uh we got the
house appraised it came in at 800. we
owe 440 on it so I'm asking a third of
the equity which is 120 and they're
offering me 80.
so I guess my question is like is
is that price fair to ask
uh is are there any other any other fees
I should consider
how old are you
I'm 32. okay is this your first like
deal that you tried to make like you and
your buddies had an idea like let's do
this and
it was is this your yeah it was uh
yeah it was a handshake too yeah did you
learn your lesson Luke yeah that's what
I'm getting at yeah yeah for sure and
for everyone listening
who's like ooh the real estate game I
can get in and me and two guys two
friends yeah we're gonna get this house
and it's gonna be awesome Luke tell
everyone why they shouldn't do that
yeah I mean they're still my friends I
like to think but it's it's definitely
changed everything changes it changes
your relationship hey um and the way you
said it I want people to hear I want to
get out of this thing so that I can buy
my wife and kid a home
talk about putting the cart before the
horse right
yeah I mean it'd be nice to upgrade you
know help
just be there for my family sorry we're
not trying to just like take you in the
ground Luke but we get this so often
it's just it's the reality and it's and
it's why we always say do not go into a
deal especially with debt uh with
friends and family because because now
you're stuck I mean like what what do we
think is a fair price like we could say
that yeah I don't know yeah but I mean
at the end of the day they have to be
the ones to decide right I mean there's
it's not split three ways you don't
legally get to leave until you guys all
decide on something and so I
if I'm you you offered 120 they uh
counter offered 80. take the math off
the table and what you think fair market
value is and this everyone's coming up
with their own numbers
your goal now is you just want to get
out with some dignity so say let's just
set up 100 and let's shake hands and
let's be done with this thing yep and if
they say no forget you you can
um
it's been a few years since
I sat with a real estate attorney but I
you can
basically you can go have a judge
dissolve the LLC and force the sale and
then split it that way
and that's a nuclear option okay okay
they can't just hold you hostage
um I think okay that would be for you to
talk to a lawyer though all right I'm
not in a position to give you legal
advice but my understanding is if I
remember correctly you can ask a judge
to dissolve it
um
all I have to say is dude if they're
gonna offer you 80 and at the end of the
day it's on Equity it's imaginary money
right it doesn't truly exist you haven't
lost anything take your 80 grand and
walk away
okay cool and I know it's frustrating
you took it on the chin it's gonna be
um Dave calls it stupid tax I I wouldn't
call it I would say you learned your
lesson man it cost you some money and
the next time you're not gonna make the
same mistake okay yeah it's a little bit
of loss there
um versus what you were saying with the
equity but just to get out of the deal
Luke honestly you'll sleep better at
night and and hopefully it doesn't ruin
the Friendship either right but let's
say this so if his friends are trying to
rip him off or they're mad at him or
whatever friends yeah yeah you know what
I mean
I know I just like having a bunch of
friends
but it's true yeah I mean
but I wonder what their reasoning is
like what's the things like you said you
were in this for a decade man yeah we're
doing everything we always do is in your
work you're yeah I mean it's it's just
it's messy and then you get married you
have a kid also in your priorities
changed that's right that's right all of
it okay up next we have Andrea in Waco
Texas hey welcome to the show
hi hello hello how can we help
okay so
um me and my husband we've been dealing
with this decision for a while now
probably about two years now so I'm a
nurse and I two years ago 2020 I got a
RNA instructor's position
um and the schedule is great for the
kids of course because it's the
teachings position but the pay is pretty
low like to the point where we have been
having to work extra shifts
um like part-time just to make ends meet
not able to save
um a opportunity came up for me to
travel starting in the spring and with
that
I will have an increase I would say like
four to five thousand more a month
um for our finances but it'll also take
away from
the the good schedule yeah because we
have little kids yeah and then
um also I think at one point over like
if I stayed in like the RN instructor's
position over time I think it's kind of
better with the 401K and
um in the position you're in knowledge
yeah in the position I'm in now with
college like the the kids college will
be paid for if I was to stay so long
term it's a good decision to stay but
then at the same time short term it's
tough going to travel nursing it'd be
and travel nursing is no joke I mean
yeah and if you have little kids at home
that's a that's a lifestyle shift yeah
it changes your whole life from the
inside out but you also are doing a good
job I mean I applaud you recognizing
reality we can't continue to burn the
candle of both ends you can do that for
a short time when you're trying to pay
off debt or trying to save up for a
house or something just to live you
can't do that just to live right so it
sounds to me like you know hold on hang
on to the line here because I want to
dig into this a little bit more so hang
on to the line uh we're gonna put you on
hold and then we will holler back at you
after the break Andrea
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show we held
a caller over from last segment Andrea
from Waco she is a nurse and between her
and her husband's job they're having to
make extra shifts just to meet or make
ends meet
and then she got an opportunity to do
travel nursing which she'll make
significantly more money but it's also
kind of a change in lifestyle and they
have little kids so the there's big
question marks Did I cover everything
Andrea correctly
yes and I want to be clear too with
travel like the specific travel that I'm
thinking of it's more so local travel so
it's like okay two hours away from home
we won't be going like far far like like
things like that going out of the state
with the kids with the kids and your
husband they go with you
um no I would just drive back and forth
okay
um and try to do like two hours or less
from home okay okay when I heard travel
nurse sorry I didn't mean to all over
the country yeah jump I was just
thinking yeah because they some
sometimes will just send you somewhere
for three months and then you go
somewhere else and then it's just kind
of it's everywhere but if it's close by
that you can travel
uh
and get there in a day you know that
within a nine to five situation then
that could be possibly a different
situation okay so what's your what's
your question for for me and John
I guess it's more so because of the
change I I know they're precious when
they're younger and I know it's it's
good to have that schedule but
also at the same time it's I think it's
a good idea to also get out of debt and
um another thing too is with travel
nursing it is not a consistency with it
at one point there's always a need but
there's
but it's not like a constant
um this amount every single month kind
of thing so I just want to make sure
that yeah it's the right decision going
forward yeah for sure okay so how much
debt you guys have
um total with everything about 90 90
okay that does not include the mortgage
right
not included mortgage or any
um education okay so if what do you mean
not any education
not any um like loans college student
loans oh how much are your student loans
oh gosh another probably 90. okay so 180
total in Consumer Debt yeah Andrea you
have to include that in your debt you
can't pretend it doesn't exist
the same thing how much are you guys
making now
a year combined
a year combined we make about uh well
I'm looking 110 000. okay and how much
would you make if you took travel
nursing a year
um
I'll make 110 by myself plus my husband
makes 45. okay so yeah you're at 155.
what does your husband do
he's a police officer okay
um
man I mean if you did this Andrea for
two years here's here's what here's
where my mind went okay because I'm a
mom with three little kids and my work I
have to have travel to because we travel
for events and all of that obviously I
know yours will be just a few hours away
from home and all of that but it still
will be grueling right you have a four
hour commute possibly on Sundays I mean
it's just gonna be longer days
potentially uh potentially so for me if
I'm in your position I'm like okay
I know in two years of doing this it's
going to be hard it's not gonna be fun
but I also am going to be able to pay
off all of our debt including the
student loans
and we're gonna be able to pay it all
off if I do this
for two years like having an end point
you know what I'm saying like mapping it
out for you guys to say and then if your
husband's able to pick up maybe an extra
job you know at nights uh if you're home
and you guys I mean you're working
baseball games or working concerts and
things like that yeah working I mean and
you could be ships passing in the nights
but only for a period of time okay
because I don't if you do this over a
long period of time you're gonna your
your kids aren't gonna know who you are
you're gonna lose your family your
marriage is gonna be disaster you can't
live like that forever but for a period
of time you guys can do a lot and you
have a lot of debt 180 000. to be able
to knock that out
uh man as as quickly as possible like it
and here's the other side of it so
possible you've got a job as an
instructor which helps so you're in Waco
there so let's just pretend it's Baylor
you gotta you have an opportunity
um
you know part of the part of your
package comes with student tuition
discount right or if you're there for a
long long time it comes with you know
after a certain number of years that
thing which is common across many
colleges
um
I have several close buddies who were
police officers who actually were
veterans and they were police officers
and then they went and worked at a
university right as their kids were
headed into college
and their kids went to school either
free or on a significant discount just
as police officers you could go in as a
staff nurse in 15 years when your kids
are that old
and get to say right so there's a lot of
avenues into that in that higher
education environment to get jobs
between you and your husband and that
would end up with getting a similar or
same benefit does that make sense
Kinda Yeah
so I would not I like what Rachel has to
say I really think a Sprint you owe a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars let
me say this another way you're going to
be infinitely more present with your
kids
if you don't owe anybody any money if
your body's not constantly banging on
the back of your skull letting you know
that you're not safe
got it
is that fair
yes how old are those little ones
one four and six yeah a couple of couple
of busy years
um will pay exponential dividends down
the road
you didn't want us to say that huh
yeah
you know or yeah and Andrea I mean and
you know or maybe another option is look
to see can you track can you switch
maybe it's not travel nursing but is
there another position somewhere that
needs a nurse and you're going to make
more than what you're making now I mean
you know what I mean like look at
options I feel like whenever we get
stuck in this tunnel if there's ever
this or that yes this or that there's
always option three and four and you
guys get creative together and again I'm
so big John says it all the time but
facts are your friends put numbers on
paper and look because to this fear this
idea is it's just in your head and it
just looms when you actually look at
numbers and you map things out and you
can move things you feel like you have
control again where you're like okay
well if we do this this if we pull this
lever we'll be out of debt in three
years we pull these two levers we could
be out of debt in 22 months you know
like you you can start to kind of play
around and actually have a game plan and
you and your husband do it together and
remember it's not going to be forever
it's not gonna be forever it's gonna be
for a short period of time but but that
intensity and attacking it that's what's
going to show you progress so our
careers they're they're a big deal John
I mean they're a big part of of our
lives and who we are and
our careers here at Ramsey Solutions you
know we have a building full of almost a
thousand people and we talk a lot about
the mission that we're on here at Ramsey
Solutions of trying to change America's
toxic money culture and it makes us mad
when we see people get in debt it makes
us mad when you don't have options
because of what you've chosen in your
past and now you're tied up financially
uh we get mad when we watch you know
kids sign away their future to student
loans and so for us here at Ramsey
Solutions it's not just a job it really
is a mission to change lives so if that
sounds like a passion that you share
you've got to check out all the exciting
roles that we have at Ramsey solutions
that we are looking to fill ASAP and
there's never been a time better than to
do work that you love so we're looking
for developers ux designers and writers
to help us build digital products that
actually change people's lives so to see
what it's like to do work that matters
with us before check out our Instagram
and Facebook by searching Ramsay careers
and apply for your dream job here at
ramseysolutions.com
careers that's
ramsaysolutions.com careers and one
important thing if you're listening to
this and you think gosh I wish my mom
could hear this or I wish my brother or
I got this guy at work please please
um you can help this show out with no
money just by subscribing to the show
leaving five star reviews it helps kick
the show up into the internet's
algorithms however that works and it
puts the show in front of more people
you can also send episodes that mean a
lot to you or that would mean a lot to
one of your friends or family members
you can send it directly to them thank
you so much for sharing the word on the
Ramsay show Absolutely we'll be back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show taking
your calls this hour I'm Rachel Cruz
with Dr John deloney
next up we have Brenda in Battle Creek
hey Brenda welcome to the show
hi thank you absolutely how can we help
uh well
I recently sold a house and I have Accu
Equity from that house what do I do with
it right now I have it in a money market
it just sold so I'll be I mean that's
why I haven't invested it yet
um but
um I I I have a 401k I have an RA Ira
um and my financial advisor suggested
going to a CD
for this money
I don't know are you gonna are you gonna
use it to buy more property soon
well possibly I don't know whether I'm
going to use the money to maybe buy a
fixer-upper and flip it that could be a
possibility yeah
um I I you know there's so many
possibilities that could happen with
this money I just want to make sure that
I'm getting
the biggest bank of the buck in the
shortest amount of time
I don't I wouldn't lose a second of
sleep over that
like Rachel and I were just talking
about this off air
also put put a price on peace
and a price on your time
like you got in a money market just let
it sit there what else do you have
Brenda do you have any debt
no no and where are you living now
um actually I have a house that is
completely paid for
um so everything's paid off amazing and
you have good cash in the bank
e well that's that's from the sale of
the house that yes is that the only cash
you have is this 140 as cash yes okay
so if I were you Brenda I mean I would
I would put some of the savings away are
you are you single married kids I'm
single single okay so if I were you I
would get six months of your expenses
price that out
take some of that from this 140 put
aside I just keep that in a money market
account and then this 140 yeah I mean at
this point it's kind of like okay you
you're at baby step seven is what we
would say when you look because you have
no mortgage you got nothing right so you
were just sitting on
um just for fun we'll say a hundred
thousand dollars for easy math so
there's three things you can do with
money you can give it you can save it
and you can enjoy it and you know at
this point I would encourage you to do
all three if there's I would give some
of this
um and find
someone something a Ministry a church uh
or even just a non-profit something that
you love a friend's kid is going to
college just gets a mystery check you
know
yeah find some way to to be generous
with some of it
um I would enjoy some of it I don't know
if you need to upgrade a car if you want
to go on a great trip or something you
know and that's the thing too I have
been saving my entire life so I can't
even hardly afford to let go of ten
dollars
put you on a vacation Brenda Brenda
Brenda I don't I don't spend money at
all right how old are you to enjoy some
of it
um I I'm I'm 51.
that's not that old you I thought you're
about to say 111. for 51. it feels like
it some days you're halfway home you are
halfway done oh my gosh you are halfway
done I am working full-time so I'm
trying to start two businesses
um I I just I just need some direction
and how to get my businesses going so I
I can enjoy the rest of what I have
without worrying about maybe spending
ten dollars for lunch you
you
oh Brenda you were you were you were
chasing peace as an external metric
you're never gonna find it out there
right you're not and if you get these
businesses stable
you'll enjoy that for about 11 and a
half
minutes
and then you will either
have to deal with Murphy's Law something
will spin off behind you and you have to
go solve it or you will just knock
something over to have something to go
fix because that's who Brenda is you're
gonna buy a house that's a piece of
trash and mix it up fix it up exactly
because I got nothing else going on in
my life right you're right I I I I say
busy I like to stay busy and I like to
have my hands in in stuff all the time
and I I I I I like to make money I I I
like all those things and
if we're not careful
um being busy is our drink of choice
exactly we become alcoholics except it's
it's we're addicted to busyness or
addicted to the next deal then the next
deal the next deal and then that deal
doesn't get us our hit anymore so we got
to go get two deals and then we start
getting real itchy and so I want you to
make yourself go on a vacation
I want you to make yourself give some
money away to somebody I want you just
to bless the ABS just
just shower somebody with with with
giving okay right and make yourself do
it and just sit in it okay just sit in
it and if you hate it then um you never
have to go on a vacation again just give
it a shot right it's pretty awesome okay
but I am kind of like looking towards
Maybe
cutting my full-time job now
am I gonna how much do you make how much
do you make now with your full-time job
about forty thousand forty thousand okay
and then how much do you make between
the two businesses that you're that
you're spinning up well I'm just
starting them up so I haven't really
made anything yet okay so how would you
make money I want to be like a hobby
okay so how would what kind of work do
you want to do then
um well it's kind of uh is kind of
incorporating a couple different
projects but basically it's going to be
um
helping
women that
have been traumatized
um
um I actually went through that and when
I was going through that and nobody was
there but since that all these women
that have come to me for advice I mean
I've been life coaching probably about
10 hours a week now I mean not paid not
really anything I'm just explaining to
them how I've been going through this
yeah and it's helping them and I want to
get together with these women and just
know that they're not alone it's awesome
that's amazing and and it it just it's
so empowering and so uplifting now
because of where I was to where now
where I am and I can see you know I dug
myself out of that hole and I want to
help other women to know that because
when I was in that hole I didn't see the
I didn't see the list well I hear I hear
the the passion in your voice and not to
make this sound transactional I had to
ask this question but for life coaching
is that something you you think
career-wise that you may start making a
living off of like hey I can counseling
people or helping them or mentoring them
but it's going to be quitting your
full-time job to do that
um not really okay it's just more of a
it's more of a gift of your heart that
you just love to do it is okay because I
don't feel like I should get paid for
that yeah that's fine you know I just I
just don't feel like yeah
I just want to make sure that just to
know I just don't want you to quit yeah
your full-time job because you need to
eat you need to have an income coming in
even though you have a great you know
100 000 left over after your emergency
fund which is awesome and you could live
off that for a few you know if you want
to take a break and be like Brenda's
gonna chill for 60 days you know go
chill that's great I think I think you
are you can but I'm saying
mathematically you can with your money
because you have no payments when you
have a hundred thousand dollars in the
bank so if you wanted to you that's an
option for you which is amazing
um but also I don't want you to quit
your full-time job without at least an
idea of kind of where I where I want to
go because it doesn't sound like the two
businesses that you're starting up
are paying anything you said they're
basically hobbies and then you have this
mentorship thing on the side that's your
heart and your passion which you just
love to do which is great so yeah I
would start to kind of narrow down
Brenda
um here's here's what I recommend you do
nothing
um this purchase uh for somebody with
your background this is a this is a
culmination of a season
and I want you to just sit for six
months and just leave the money where
it's at like Rachel said I would pull
that money out for your emergency fund
pull it into an account where it goes
but just sit and Let the Smoke Clear on
this and continue living your life don't
quit your job yet but give yourself
about six months to Let the Smoke Clear
and say okay what's my next move and
you're gonna have a lot clearer ahead in
a few months it's great Brenda thanks
for calling you're awesome this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
Matthew 7 12. so then in everything
treat others the same way you want them
to treat you for this is the essence of
the law and the writing of the prophets
when you're good to others you're best
to yourself Benjamin Franklin
I'm Rachel Cruz with Dr John deloney
taking your calls this hour so you'll
hear us say all the time that everyone
needs a will and it's true it's a basic
adult responsibility and there's just no
really good excuse not to have one so
you'll always hear me recommend an
online
will because it's the fastest that's the
most cost effective way to make sure
that your will is taken care of but also
I get a lot of questions asking okay
it's a simple online will right for
everyone in my specific situation what
if I need a trust or what if I need a
mirror will or what kind of powers of
attorney am I going to need lots of
questions are in people's minds so our
team actually built a quiz to help you
find the right option for you you'll get
a custom results based on basic info
like if you're married or single where
you live even the size of your estate so
you'll know exactly what you need to do
in your specific situation so to take
the quiz and find out what kind of will
you need to protect your family visit
ramseysolutions.com
Wills quiz to check it out for yourself
all right we're going to John in Tacoma
Washington hey John welcome to the show
hi guys how are you doing we're doing
great how can we help
uh so my question is my fiance and I are
getting married in November and
congratulations trying to figure out
thank you trying to figure out how do we
budget for the month of November because
we're getting married on the 11th so how
do we budget for like
the first 10 days and then the the rest
like do we do a separate budgets or do
we just do one budget for us together
because we won't be married till the
11th John so appreciate your question I
really appreciate it I was gonna say
something mean have you have you met her
what Rachel no no no you're what your
fiance you all talked right
if you and I were hanging out I'd be
making some jokes but I don't know you
that well so gosh John you know what I
was sorry I would start it in December
and I would say start at November one
okay so there you go there you go wow
interesting he's like I don't know we we
get a terrible advice the last time
what's the hold up John I so appreciate
that but you're so diligent what's
making is she is she is like nerdy when
it comes to the budget As You Are
hey she is lucky to have married you I
know
um I bet she's throwing a disco at your
wedding
look I I I think oh that's gonna be me I
think I think it's a conversation and
and like I say I would sit down in
November and say hey here's I mean
you're both going to get paid at the
beginning of November or the end of
October and say Here's what our budget's
gonna look like and
um we can move forward this way or you
both take your budgets and you carry
them in and you go get married and then
you have your honeymoon and then you
come back at the end of November and you
settle in for December giving all that
December 1 first budget that's what I'd
say
to just kind of run it up be crazy for
15 days for 15. you got two weeks John
put the nerd one down and just go for it
okay because we have the the account
together already just for the wedding
stuff yeah because I've heard Rachel
talk about it in the password you have
like our account together it's just for
wedding and when you get married sure
throw everything in there you have to
count together so we'll have an account
together yeah that's great yeah then put
all the money in
I mean you could even do that November I
mean you're 10 days out like it's like
when we say when you say I do you
combine your finances immediately I mean
like
yes like we don't want people doing that
when they're dating or when they're
engaged and they have nine more months
of planning their wedding but you guys
are 11 days out at some point you've got
to sign a lease yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you're good you're good I I would I
would just take a few deep breaths John
here's the important thing you all talk
to it y'all talk about it together and
don't the worst thing you can do on the
eve of your wedding is to go and say hey
I called a couple of Knuckleheads on the
radio and here's what we're gonna do
that's not a way to start a marriage I
would go to her and say
um what do you think the best way to do
this is I'm thinking we settle it up for
December and I don't think she's gonna
care I I 100 know she's not gonna be
there not even a little bit she's gonna
go hi John I love you and that's a great
job cool November one I love you
December one I love you yes it's great
January 15th I love even more but here
here's the key you'll do it together yes
yes decide together and you're great
thanks John I appreciate your diligence
I really appreciate your diligence so
great right okay up next we got Drew in
um not sure no answer
reading's hard reading's hard what's up
Drew
hi thanks so much for taking my call uh
what I like to do is just give you my
vitals real quick and then I'll ask uh
my question cool I'm currently about 192
000 in debt I get paid about 152 000 a
year 104 of that is uh for my salary and
48 000 is about my military retirement
I'm currently upside down uh on two cars
collectively at about ten thousand
dollars I'm currently enrolled in Ramsey
plus I'm on baby step two and I'm side
hustling as a door Dasher so my question
is this should focus on paying down
those two upside down cars and and or
and then get rid of them or should I go
with the traditional smallest to largest
debt
how much are you upside down did you say
10 000 on each
uh no 10 000 collectively collectively
okay between both of them what's the
What's the total loans on them
oh it's outrageous they're uh 38 048
000 something like that okay I would
honestly Drew I would get rid of both of
them take it alone for the difference
um just so you're not you're not paying
those payments every month I mean that's
just a lot so knocking out eighty
thousand dollars of debt and dropping it
to fifteen thousand that's a huge huge
advancement yep so I would sell both as
long as I can't take uh I can't take a
long I tried doing the loan uh because
basically I went online to see what
they've had to say about it he said take
out a loan but unfortunately my credits
course was terrible right now that I
couldn't take out a loan I would have to
do it I would have to literally do
minimums on all the other debts and
focus on one vehicle at a time and
that's that's what I was wondering if I
guess I got my answer right it's just a
focus on getting rid of those two cars
uh keeping them at the 38 and the 48
like if you just keep them as is
no what I'm saying is it's like because
I can't I can't take that alone what I
was thinking is is pausing or just
paying the minimum on the other debts
and then have you gone have you gone to
a local credit union Drew
I have not it's everything online
yeah go to a local credit union and look
somebody in the eye yeah I would go in
person somewhere I mean and go multiple
places if you get one no that they won't
um you know give you this this loan for
the difference go to somewhere else
somewhere else and usually Credit Unions
local or local banks State Banks will be
better than like a Bank of America or
something a national especially somebody
with a guaranteed pension coming in
you've got a check coming in every every
month yeah and
when you go to an online bank you just
you're an algorithm you're you fall into
a baboon baba boom boom here's the
output when you go Shake somebody's hand
at a credit union in your local
community sometimes it's different it
may not be but Rachel the broader
question let's say no no one will help
him out
this is such a massive part of his debt
does he pause everything save up 10
grand go in and sell these things and
they're upside down or do you just roll
them into the baby steps uh I would
probably yeah I'd save up to 10 grand I
think it would the amount of money he's
spending every month on payments yes
would would outweigh it accelerate yeah
yeah but I wouldn't say oh I'm gonna go
try to pay off the 38 000 loan no no
it's just to get rid of them yeah
exactly exactly uh but thanks for the
call Drew I appreciate it yikes
um
it it it is fascinating to me always uh
hearing people and thank you drew two
for your service
um
who who have kind of like
really gone in with this stuff and
they're like okay I'm Gonna Change I'm
gonna change this and you hear it in
their voice I mean I just heard it even
in Drew's voice so if you're out there
just as a word of encouragement and
you've not started this process and
you're thinking golly we're living
paycheck to paycheck this is how life is
just know like this show is a testimony
to the fact that it doesn't have to be
that way what the world says is so
normal and how it's always going to be
that does not have to be your story and
you hear people like Drew and so many
others throughout this three hours today
that man they're making radical
decisions with their life and they're
actually getting control of their life
so it's a beautiful thing John always
fun to host with you and thank you
America for listening thanks to everyone
in the booth
we got James spin Zach Andrew Austin
Jenna thank you America we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people a lot of those people
peeps radio stations across the
near you go to ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]